this is gonna be a huge summer at the
movies full superheroes giant monsters
talking animals and Charles Manson so
stay with us while we break down our 10
most anticipated movies of the season
Avengers end game after 11 years in the
MCU were finally getting the grand
finale fans been looking forward to this
ever since Thanos snapped half the
universe into oblivion and everyone's
anxious to see how the Avengers bounced
back to defeat him
will time travel be involved will Tony
Stark er Steve Rogers sacrificed
themselves to save humanity will ant-man
take the literal plunge and explode
Thanos from the inside and what's with
Hawkeye's new haircut we'll find out on
April 26th whatever it takes
detective Pikachu who could have guessed
that the perfect guy to play Deadpool
would also be the perfect guy to voice
Pikachu Brian Reynolds stars as the
cuddly adorable Pokemon who helps a
former pokémon trainer played by justice
Smith discovered the truth about his
father if anyone was skeptical about a
live-action treatment of the popular
video game characters all doubt was
erased by the hilarious trailer which
made fans squeal with images of
Jigglypuff Bulbasaur and Charizard
the video game adaptations are notorious
for being terrible but here's hoping
this movie can break the curse detective
Pikachu arrives on May 10th John wick
chapter 3 Parabellum John wick is
officially excommunicate Oh as Keanu
Reeves returns to play the most deadly
hit man who ever lost a puppy the third
film picks up where chapter 2 left off
with John wick on the run from pretty
much every assassin he hasn't killed yet
Laurence Fishburne and Ian McShane also
return and are joined by Halle Berry
Angelica Huston and Jason Mantzoukas
expect the trilogy to close out with
expertly choreographed hand-to-hand
combat motorcycle swordplay and John
wick on a horse oh and of course
headshots lots of headshots John wick
chapter 3 opens on May 17th what do you
need
guns lots of guns Godzilla king of the
monsters sometimes you just want to see
giant monsters beat the crap out of each
other on the biggest screen possible and
that's exactly what Godzilla king of the
monsters promises sure you've got
Godzilla himself did you know he's
actually an official citizen of Japan
but the new movie puts them up against
classic rivals like Mothra Rodin and
King Ghidorah
and we can't wait to see what those
battles will look like at a cast that
includes Kyle Chandler beer Farmiga and
eleven herself Millie Bobby Brown and
this is a Royal Rumble that looks worth
the price of admission Godzilla king of
the monsters opens on May 31st
one Luther King men in black
international Thor and Valkyrie trade in
their hammer and sword for a couple of
big guns as Chris Hemsworth and Tessa
Thompson suit up to revive the men in
black they're joined by Liam Neeson as
the head of M IVs UK office while
Rebecca Ferguson and Kumail Nanjiani
lent their voices to a pair of aliens
sure we don't have Will Smith or time to
Lee Jones anymore fingers crossed for a
cameo maybe but it's a fun universe that
we're happy to return to with some fresh
blood and a new spin men in black
international hits theaters on June 14th
looks like it sometime
toy story for look we thought Toy Story
3 was a beautiful fitting goodbye to
Woody Buzz and the rest of the gang but
we're not gonna argue with Pixar wants
to give us more time with them we made a
new toy named for ki who's not exactly
thrilled about being a toy and it's up
to woody to help him fit in longtime
Pixar animator Josh coolly takes the
reins and the regular cast is joined by
new characters voiced by Jordan Steele
keegan-michael key Christina Hendricks
and Keanu Reeves while veep's Tony Hale
will provide plenty of freak-outs
as for Keith the Toy Story 4 hits
theaters on June 21st
nothing about science
spider-man far from home
wait isn't Peter Parker currently a pile
of dust on the planet Titan I guess we
can assume he makes it out of Avengers
endgame ok especially since Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige has said that
spider-man will be the one to Shepherd
audiences into the post Thanos phase of
the MCU Jake Gyllenhaal shows up his
classics fight evil and Mysterio he's
even got the fishbowl helmet but the
trailer makes him out to be a good guy
which has our spidey sense tingling
we'll see how it all plays out with
spider-man far from home swings into
theaters on July 5th
so nice to finally meet you in spite of
me The Lion King the 1994 animated The
Lion King is one of Disney's most
beloved movies
so this live-action remake is gonna be
big director Jon Favreau has already
proven he can handle this sort of
project with his fantastic remake of The
Jungle Book and it's got an all-star
voice path that includes Donald Glover
and Beyonce as Simba and Nala as well as
two Attell Ejiofor Seth Rogen alfre
woodard and the legendary James Earl
Jones returning to play Mufasa that's
more than enough to make anyone sing
Hakuna Matata The Lion King opens on
July 19th
once upon a time in Hollywood Quentin
Tarantino has been pretty skimpy with
details about his 9th movie but the fact
that it's him is basically enough to
raise expectations sky-high what we do
know is that it takes place in Los
Angeles in 1969 and focuses on a movie
star played by Leonardo DiCaprio and his
stunt man played by Brad Pitt the insane
ensemble cast also includes Al Pacino
Kurt Russell and Margot Robbie who play
Sharon Tate one of the victims of the
Manson Family murders we don't know how
much Charles Manson himself will figure
into the story but as co-star Bruce Dern
told us
Tarantino did the single most
unpredictable thing I've ever seen a
director do in this movie he had our
curiosity now he has our attention once
upon a time in Hollywood opens on July
26th that was the best acting I've ever
seen in my whole life thank you
Hobbs and Shah maybe you thought gee
there's just too many characters to keep
track of in the Fast and Furious movies
I wish they would focus on just a couple
of them preferably two who don't like
each other very much and force them to
work together to defeat a superpower
Deidre's Elva if so then you're in luck
because this is exactly that dwayne
johnson brute force meets Jason
Statham's martial arts skills as they
pair up to throw clips at each other
beat up bad guys blow things up and save
the world it's a kind of high-octane
action we've come to expect from the
franchise and we're all for it
Hobbs and shot opens on August 2nd bad
guy
there you have it our top 10 most
anticipated movies of the summer now
it's your turn
comment right now and let us know which
flicks are you most excited about this
season
[Music]
you